the world is filled with pain and misery
and problems
that's it so humans have a
distinct trait of wanting to solve these
problems but it doesn't always go well
so today we're going to cherish and
appreciate all the failed attempts of
making our lives easier
here's some uh to start off some crazy
inventions from the past
a brush that simultaneously shines your
scalp and brushes your hairy sides
while we finally
baby suspender they are also ice skating
hey that baby looks like he's having a
good time goddamn these were better
times
there was no child safety involved in
everything oh that's not safe for the
baby
a face cover to protect from
rain
snow etc etc eh we could use that today
bring that one back please ain't nobody
gonna go near you
with that thing on your face
hell yeah
a neck brush rubs against your skin as
you move your head
why it looks like a torture machine
look at the child he loves it he's
having a great time
whoa dude whoa
oh that's i mean that's cleveland
but whoa radio hat
hell yeah taking the walkman for a walk
look at that thing god damn
i'm listening to what i'm sorry
what is that
baby's first gas pram i'm sorry what it
i'm sorry what
motorized surfboard what i saw that
swedish
uh my dude plagiarized
the 20s
[Laughter]
it's already a thing that's so baller
dude how
a device to teach children how to walk
hell yeah i don't know why it's funnier
that these are old right because that
means people actually tried it it's not
just some
gag or something right or maybe it isn't
it's not obvious
walk child whether you like it or not
you shall walk
you dumb mommy and dad
hangover mask oh sh which need that
how how how
why why why
[Laughter]
with a sewing machine mom will
get off the sewing machine
put it on the bike the modern one is the
kid is
on a laptop playing fortnite all right
what modern inventions do we have that
helps
helps our future bread gloves is that
real
that is photoshop that is definitely
photoshop bread gloves
my dude just shove your hand into a loaf
pizza scissors that's not terrible
is it this is me i up with a pizza
scissor
why do i there's certain things that we
we just haven't solved yet right
people are never satisfied with the
pizza regular pizza cutter
am i the only one in the world that eats
a pizza with knife and fork and start
from the middle and going out because i
don't like the crust
this has never been a problem for me and
it will never be a problem for me
just spray glh on i was always so
confused by this do people use this
leaving you with great looking hair glh
is not a pain this i remember seeing
like whoa there you go
that clings to the tongue oh it's his
hair it actually
goes on leaving you with great great
looking hair
is not expensive wow that's incredible
this is the first time i've ever used
this product i
saw it on the infomercials and i was
skeptical at first
it works i'll tell you i can't believe
it you know i've seen the commercial
and i i just couldn't believe it no more
dates about being called old man
but the babes are back the babes are
back and they quoted it
the babes are back bowling is another
issue that's no one's really solved yet
right
can't wait to run my fingers through
your paint to be fair we will probably
solve bowling in the future right
because it's a
genetic thing and if you're able to
change your dna
which we definitely will be and this
won't be a problem
there's hope for you bald people plus
being bold doesn't look that bad
the hula chair
but that will strengthen your core
that's amazing i want it
maybe that should be the next thing for
the pewdiepie chair
plastic grocery bags time magazine
posted this are you serious
yeah they were supposed to save trees
they were supposed to be reused
that the production of them are not that
bad the problem is that they are so
cheap that everyone just
don't reuse them the point was that
people should reuse them
that's not fair i'm biased here because
they're they were invented by a swedish
person
you are welcome planet earth for dying
okay so this is the
rujevenic electric facial mask
an electric face smack that's supposed
to reduce wrinkles by
exercising the face muscles because in
essence rejuvenating does for the face
what exercise does for the body
wow and the way it does that is there's
a control unit that during a facial
session
actually sends an impulse ah don't look
at me
and actually activates the face and skin
to exercise tighten and tone
these impulses start in the forehead
bruh
that you could launch this today and
people would still buy it i guarantee
you man i guarantee it
no one cared who i washed and i put on
the mask
my wrinkles are non-existent
wait no someone tried to do a flying car
there's a flying car
there are flying cars are you kidding me
death by flying car ah god damn it
[Laughter]
that looks baller dude the a
miser was a real flying car
in the 1970s god blessed the 70s a small
company
brought flying cars closer to reality
than ever hey
it flew ah
he had to emergency land but he realized
he couldn't
uh land anywhere so he just went into a
bean field
close to the airport and then drove the
airplane on the road back to the airport
what's the pro this is so cool
we need to bring this back
even even please
please it looks sick dude i love this
am i the only one i've never heard of
this the comfort wipe
100 years we've been scrunching and
folding toilet paper
there's a better way comfort oh i've
seen this oh god damn it extension arm
and holder
that is that thing is not going in my
ass that's just not happening
it extends your reach a full 18 inches
whoa that is so
far unless i had to wipe someone else's
ass
then yes this would actually be a good
thing right god created mankind to
perfectly wipe his own ass
i don't need extension arm it's as easy
to use as a shower brush
well it but it's not it's not supposed
to
be okay all right comfort wipe
if my anus was on my shoulder then yes i
would use your product
vibrating ab belt dude i still see these
they are still a thing some things are
just like inherent in us where we just
like
there has to be an easy solution i don't
want to just work out
right so there's one for 30 bucks and
there's one for 300 bucks this is the
one i've seen
because i saw this in japan because
japan loves dumb gadgets
look he's ripped so therefore um
need help to tone up in those stubborn
areas
that's just false advertising i know
they can
say that they meant like oh you want to
tone up the muscle
but clearly people will think like oh i
have a little betty fat
i want to get rid of that that's not how
it works you can't just target one area
of your body
yo what no
five star reviews you're telling me
people
are just well thousands of people are
working around sick back
get out of here get the out get the
out who's done
this is a scam i click on the review and
it takes me nowhere
refunds and cancellations our customer
satisfaction a priority
we had the 14 day money back area all
right fine fine
fine fine so there's a study that showed
positive results for strengthening
muscles with it
but the study showed no improvement when
it came to actual body composition
which is probably what you want right
should i make a video trying this
out carbonated flavored milk
give me that give me that carbon milk
bruh oh they went out of business
does anyone have it i want to try it
wait coca-cola owned it
that's amazing that makes it even better
let's see japan because japan is really
the country of
of uh problems to solutions they just
love coming up with this stuff
hearing enhancer those are
baller i want those
that's amazing battle scratch shirt this
is
genius amazing japan you did it
god damn it i expect a dumber stuff no
no holy
the french moves
at last at last
god bless you japan self-driving car
no thank you self driving fridge
give me that give me that give me that
now i want it now
voice activated
you know this would actually work in my
place in japan
because our living room is next to our
kitchen
and our living room is like lower down
so i would actually like hey fridge get
over here
i wouldn't even have to like oh go down
i mean hell yeah
i'm getting um kid can't stop me
the flying umbrella
see this is what i like i want the new
stuff as well
they put a drip my guy you put a drone
on an
umbrella what will it just follow you
wherever you go
or
[Music]
but what about the rain it looks like
who covers the umbrella yeah this is
going to have a
short circuit now
oh wow
[Music]
wow that's it that's
it that's it i like the idea that an
umbrella i don't have to hold it right
it just follows me wherever i go that's
sick
that's an idea you just put a drone in
an umbrella my dude
i could do that yeah no that's not a bad
idea because
japan is really limited on space that's
not a bad idea at all
overpriced shaped melons well first of
all
the fruit in japan is like on another
level that's kind of cool
also there's a whole gift culture in
japan so you want to give someone
something weird here have a melon it's
great it i'll
i would gladly take that all right let's
look at more modern stuff and it's just
to roll out cancer screening camera
capsules for at home care
pill cam well isn't this a thing already
i swear to god i've heard about this
to see if they have bowel cancer well i
mean i'll rather get a pill cam than a
finger off my ass i vote
i'll tell you that see this stuff is
cool
new retinas implants may give artificial
vision to the blind
what may that's a very
vague way of putting it i just want to
see what we get to look forward to in
the future right
hologram touch screens definitely seem
like that will become a thing right
we may not get flying cars but we get
solar powered bench
that charge your phone and offer gee
thanks a lot okay dumb dumb
i already have those stop what the
hell yeah aqua treadmill sign me up man
that's awesome
oh my god flying cars please flying cars
flying cars please you're flying very
close to the ground even when you're
driving
totally new possibilities and experience
nope explain to me why it looks like a
helicopter but it needs a runway
during all that design prototypes nobody
had the balls to speak up and say
it's a helicopter not a plane hell yeah
stop it stop it i want a flying car that
goes
is that too much to ask there's nothing
to look forward to
sake future the fuse can suck my
ass i'm so pissed off dude
energy storing bricks i don't give a
about brakes
sweat powered smart watches
wait floating farms that's kind of sick
whoa
how it worked though to mitigate
pollution
got it don't care how do you harvest the
ones on top how do you water it don't
ask questions
i'm so upset well that that is it for
future inventions and from the past
it's still going to suck let's get real
here
they met in the phone and i hate it
i hate it all i hate it all i don't care
thanks for watching this video
if you're not excited for the future
smash like if you are excited for the
future
smash like subscribe for every
subscriber i get
i will get another subscriber so that's
sick see you guys